اهلا بكم مشاهدينا العربيه تتابع معكم
التطورات المتلاحقه ليس فقط في السودان
ولكن ايضا التطورات في موسكو بعد استهداف
الكريم
نتابع معكم بابرز التطورات في موسكو وايضا
في السودان بالاضافه الى مجموعه من
الاخبار الدوليه
ادوما الروسيه يدعو لتدمير نظام كياب بعد
استهداف الكرملين و واشنطن لا تستطيع
التثبت من حقيقه الهجوم
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه تتهم موسكو باختلاق
الهجوم على الكرملين وتتوقع هجوما روسيا
شاملا
ومن اخبارنا الدوليه
الامم المتحده تدعو كل الاطراف السودانيه
لحمايه المساعدات وتعلن نهب قافله كانت في
طريقها لدارفور
اشتباكات بين قوات الاحتياطيه المركزي
وقوات الدعم السريع قرب القصر الجمهوري
بالخرطوم
ونحن معكم مشاهدينا في متابعه مباشره
لتطورات الاحداث في موسكو حيث اتهمت كييف
بمحاوله اغتيال اتهمت بمحاوله اغتيال رئيس
الروسي عبر هجوم بمسيره على مؤكده انها
سترد على الهجوم بالوقت والمكان المناسبين
وفي اول اجراء احترازي منعت روسيا طيران
المسيرات فوق العاصمه موسكو نائب رئيس
مجلس الدومه الروسيه قال ان الوقت قد حان
لاطلاق هجوم صاروخي على مقر اقامه الرئيس
الاوكراني
فيما ردت رئاسه الاوكرانيه بالنفي مؤكده
ان لا علاقه لها بالهجوم على الكرملين اما
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
فقال ان واشنطن لا تستطيع التاكد من صحه
الهجوم الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
هذا واظهر مقطع فيديو نشره الكريم ما يرجح
انهما رجل امن كان يصعدان الى قبه قبه
المبنى قبل هجوم المسيره بثوان كما نشاهد
في هذا الفيديو لم يتضح بعد ما اذا كان
رجل الامن في مهمه امنيه لاعتراض او
التشويه على المسيرتين ام ان الكريم كما
اكد في بيان عدم وقوع اي ضحايا او اضرار
ماديه
هذا وقالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه انه لا
علاقه لاوكرانيا بهجمات الطائرات بدون
طيار التي تعرض لها الكريم وبينها تركز
حاليا على تحرير اراضيها التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه حيث وصفت الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه تصريحات الروسيه بالخدعه
وبانها مقدمه لهجوم روسي شامل كما اشارت
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه الى ان المعارضه
الروسيه قد تكون وراء الهجوم على الكرملين
السيارات الاوكرانيه او تم اطلاقا من اوكر
انيا كما تعرفون الان سيدي الرئيس زياره
رسميه فنلندا وما سمعتش اي تاكيدات بان
مسيرات اوكرانيه
وبعد هجوم طائره مسيره على مبنى الكريم
لان قال رئيس الاوكراني
كلما زاد الضغط على العدو كلما انتهى
العدو بشكل اسرع كما صرح زينسكي بان هذا
العام سيكون عاما حاسما لنصر اوكرانيا على
روسيا
هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينك ان واشنطن لا يمكنها التحقق من صحه
تقارير استهداف بوتين في الكرملين
بمسيارات واضاف بلينكن ان امريكا تنظر
بعين الريبه لكل ما يصدر عن الكرملين واكد
انها لا تعرف ما الذي حدث هناك بالضبط كما
قال بلينكن ان قرارات اوكرانيا لكيفيه
الدفاع عن نفسها تعود لها وحدها واشنطن
واثقه بانها ستنجح باستعاده ما تبقى من
اراضيها
وتنضم الينا من امام الكرملين
كيف تبدو الاجراءات الان حول الكرملين هل
من استعدادات امنيه مختلفه هناك بيانات
تشير الى منع التحليق الطيران فوق
الكرملين ضعين في الصوره
مرحبا رشا بالفعل نحن امام الكرملين الان
نقف كما ترين حسب الصوره هناك امن تجديد
امني موسع حول ساحه الحمراء طبعا كما تدين
امامي هناك تقف الشرطه وتمنع من دخول
المواطنين او المره تمنع دخولها من نحو
اتجاه ساحه الحمراء طبعا هذا ياتي هذا
التجديد اولا ياتي بعد سقوط المسيرتين
التي سقطتها يوم ليله او يوم امس على
الكريم بالاضافه لذلك هناك تحضيرات التي
ايضا اذا كانت واضحه هناك الاعلام الحمراء
والزرقاء والتاسعه من مايو هي تحضيرات
اعيد النصر والتدريبات التي تقوم بها
القوات الروسيه داخل الساحه الحمراء
تحضيرا لعيد النصر كما اعتادت موسكو ان
التحضيرات تقوم قبيله اسبوع لذلك هناك
دائما تجديد امني يمنع من دخول المراه الى
داخل الساحه الحمراء او يمنع من مرور
السيارات بجانب الساحه الحمراء لذلك
التجديد امني هو قبيله السقوط المسيرتين
والان التجديد هو اكبر بعد سقوط المسيرتين
التي كما تحدث الكرملين ان الجانب
الاوكراني هو من قام باطلاق هذه المسيرات
التي سقطت يوم امس وكان الاستهداف طبعا هو
الرئيسي استهداف الرئيس الروسي الذي وصفته
موسكو ايضا بانه عمل ارهابي هناك دعوات
كانت من جانب الروسي من قبل رئيس مجلس
الدوما الذي وصف الرئيس الاوكراني بانه
ارهابي بانه يقوم بتهديد الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وبالتالي بتهديد روسيا
باجمعها وبالتالي هو دعا الى استخدام
اسلحه جديده لم تستخدمها روسيا خلال
العمليه العسكريه لتستهدف بها مقر القياده
الاوكرانيه داخل كييف هذه الدعوات اليوم
نسمعه من عده نواب من قبل نواب مجلس
الدومه التي اعتبرت هذا الحادث هو بمثابه
اختراق للخطوط الحمراء التي تضعها
باستهداف الشخص الرئيس الروسي واستهداف
الكريم وبالتالي كما قالت انه سيكون هناك
رد من جانب الروسي روسيا ستحدد كيفيه الرد
وتوقيت الرد على هذا الحادث الذي وقع يوم
امس طبعا هو الاول من نوعه اختراق الاراضي
الروسيه طبعا كنا شاهدنا دائما هناك هجوم
من قبل المسيرات ولكنه الاول من نوعه الذي
يتم فيه اختراق قلب العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
وهو الساحه الحمراء قبيله عيد النصر ومن
خلال التحضيرات لعيد النصر الذي سنشده
خلال ايام المقبله اذا كانت لديك اي
معلومات حول هذا الفيديو الذي يتمثه لوجود
رجلي امن في
قمه القبه ويبدو ان كانت هناك محاولاتنا
هذا الفيديو يحمل دلالات عسكريه كبيره
يعني هل هناك تفسير ات لهذا الفيديو
بالفعل تداولت الوسائل الاعلام اولا اكثر
من فيديو لهذا الحادث ولكن منها من يظهر
بها رجلان
يتوجهان نحو القبه ولكن حقيقه لا يوجد حتى
الان اي تعليق من الجانب الرسميه حول طبعا
يعني من هم هذا الرجلان ماذا كان يفعلان
على القبه هل هم خلال الحادث او قبيل
الحادث صعد الى هذه القبه لذلك حتى الان
من الصعب ان التكهن بماهيتها او الاشخاص
الذين كانوا يصعدون الى هذه القبه ولكن
اريد ان اشير الى ان السقوط الطائرات
المسيره هي لم تكن يعني متزامنه معا لكن
السقوط كان هو بشكل متتالي وبالتالي لربما
هذا الرجلان قد صعد بعد سقوط الطائره
الاولى المسيره وبالتالي صعد الرجلان
وسقطت المسيره الاخرى لذلك من الصعب
التكهن الان حول ماهيه هؤلاء الاشخاص
الذين
كانوا متواجدين
هل كانوا هم صاعدين لاطفاء او اخماد
الحريق الذي نشب عن سقوط المسيره الاولى
لانها سقطت المسيره الاولى سقطت حوالي
الساعه الثانيه ونصف ليلا اما
المسيره الثالثه فقط سقطت بعد نحو ربع او
عشرين دقيقه من سقوط المسيره الاولى
وبالتالي لربما كان هناك طبعا بالتاكيد
رده فعل مباشره لرجال الامن وصعود لاخماد
الحريق او لتفقد القبه في حال كان هناك
اضرار نجمت عن سقوط المسيره الاولى لذلك
رشه هناك حقيقه اسئله عديده
هل هل هناك اضرار اضرار وقعت في الكرمله
النتيجه هذا القصف لان الصوره لا توضح
يعني توضح الانفجار ولكن الاضرار لا تبدو
واضحه هل وقعت اضرار ام انه لم تقع اضرار
نتيجه هذا الهجوم وهو امر قد يكون غريب
هو حقيقه كما تحدث الكرملين هي قامت
باصابه المسيرات التي سقطت وبالتالي كان
هناك فقط حطام لهذه المسيرات التي سقطت
على سطح الكرملين كما شاهد كما شاهدنا
بالفيديو هناك اشتعال للحريق ولكنه حريق
صغير نشب عن سقوط هذه المسيره التي تم
اصابتها
بنظام الدفاع الجوي
في الكرملين وبالتالي الحريق لم يكن كبيرا
ولذلك لا نستطيع ان نؤكد فيما اذا كان
هناك بالفعل ضرر كبير لسطح الكرملين او هو
فقط حريق صغير تم اخماده بشكل سريع
والسيطره عليه ولكن كما ترين الان الصوره
امامك
والحركه اولا هي كما طبيعيه لا يوجد اي
اضرار ولا نستطيع ان نرى اي وجود اي اثار
لهذا الحطام حطام المسيرات التي سقطت مساء
يوم امس او ليله يوم امس مفسره لماذا تم
الاعلان اليوم وليس لحظه وقوع هذا الهجوم
هل ثم هل ثم التفسير لهذا الامر
حقيقه رشا يعني من قراءه الخبراء
لهذا الامر هو اولا الكرملين قام بالحديث
عنه صباح اليوم بعد الحادث لربما هو جاء
بعد التاكد من ان هذه المسيرات هي بالفعل
يعني سيارات ليست هي مسيرات العدو كما
يقول الجانب الروسي قادمه من الجانب
الاوكراني لان كما تعلمين قبيله سقوط هذه
المسيرات كان من المسموح استخدام المسيرات
والطائرات بدون طيار في الاجواء الروسيه
لذلك نحن لا نستطيع تخمين لماذا قام
الكرملين بالاعلان ليس الاعلان الفوري كما
نقول ولكن الاعلال في صباح اليوم الثاني
لذلك لربما كما قلت لك كان هناك دواعي
امنيه اولا لتجديد الامن في المنطقه لعدم
يعني نشر الهلع بين سكان العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو لان كما تعلمين الحادث في الليل
وبالتالي في نشر هذه المعلومات ليلا لقد
يؤدي الى هلا في بين اشكرك على هذا السؤال
نعم شكرا
من امام الكرملين وهذه الصور للعربيه الان
من امام الكرملين حيث الحركه الطبيعيه
للغايه ولكن هناك تعزيزات امنيه مكثفه
وفقا لمراسله العربيه ينضموا الينا من
ثياب الصحفي محمد البابا مرحبا بك سيد
محمد كيف تبدو الساحه الاوكرانيه تفاعلا
مع هذا الحدث خاصه مع ما يبدو من اتهامات
بتنفيذ هذا الهجوم
يعني حتى قبل قليل متحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه نفى ان تكون هناك اي
علاقه للقوات الاوكرانيه والجيش الاوكراني
بالهجوم الذي حصل او المسيرات التي سقطت
على سقف الكريم ليله امس حتى يعني المتحدث
باسم الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
وخلال يعني على شبكه التواصل الاجتماعي
تيليجرام نفى ان تكون لا يعني حرفيا كتب
لا علاقه لاوكرانيا بالهجوم الذي حصل على
في موسكو ليله امس ما يعني ان الجانب
الاوكراني حتى هذه اللحظه يتنصل من اي
علاقه لاوكرانيا وينفي علاقته بالهجوم
الذي حصل في الكرملين وهذه المره الاولى
التي يكون هناك موقف حاسم من السلطات
الاوكرانيه حول عمل ما حصل داخل العمق
الروسي او داخل الاراضي الروسيه حيث خلال
الفتره الماضيه كانت السلطات الاوكرانيه
تمتنع عن التعليق على هذه العمليات او اي
عمليه داخل العمق الروسي حتى نذكر يعني
قبل سبعه اشهر يعني ان الجانب الاوكراني
التزم الصمت
استفهام كبرى تصريحات الرئيس الاوكراني
ذليسكي بعد الاعلان عن هذا الهجوم كانت
تحمل معاني مفتوحه حينما يقول ان الضغط
على العدو هو
الوسيله الاكثر
فاعليه
لانتهاء العدوان بشكل اسرع هذا يحمل معنى
ضمي يمكن ان يدين اوكرانيا في هذا الامر
من وجهه نظر البعض كيف تبدو تصريحات
زينسكي
يعني هذه التصريحات التي كانت خلال
المؤتمر الصحفي الذي قال كان الرئيس
الاوكراني مع الرئيس الفنلندي وكان الحديث
بحسب يعني المتحدث باسم الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ان الحديث كان يتعلق بالعقوبات
او حزمه عقوبات جديده سيتخذه الاتحاد
الاوروبي يعني بحق روسيا بسبب عدوانها
وغزوها للاراضي الاوكرانيه وان الرئيس
الاوكراني كان يتحدث عن حسمه عقوبات ايضا
اوكرانيه بحق مسؤولين الروس وبحق يعني عدد
من القاده الروس ستتخذها اوكرانيا في
اوكرانيا خلال الايام القليله المقبله
يعني معظم المواقف التي كان يطلقها الرئيس
الاوكراني وهذه التغريده التي يعني حتحسب
او يعني كان البعض يحاول ربط هذه التغريده
بالهجوم الذي حصل بيل كريميلين ان يعني
الرئيس الاوكراني كان يقصد انه يجب الضغط
على روسيا لوقف عدوانها بينما كان حديث
الرئيس الاوكراني مقتصر بالعقوبات التي
تقوم بها اوكرانيا فيها الاتحاد الاوروبي
او العقوبات التي ستقوم بها الدول
الاوروبيه بحق روسيا لذلك لا علاقه كما
يعني كما حصلنا على توضيح من الاداره
الرئاسيه لها علاقه لهذه التغريده او لهذا
الموقف
الرئيسي
بما حصل في موسكو او الهجوم الذي حصل ليله
امس صدر
رئون هناك ثمه علاقه ما بين تصريحات
زلنيسكي عن تجديد العقوبات او تصعيد
الهجوم على روسيا وبين هذا الهجوم الذي
حدث بمسيارات على الكرملين وان هذه
التصريحات الخاصه
جاءت ردا على سؤال يتعلق بتكثيف العلاقات
وليس وليس الهجوم على الكريم من هذه نقطه
نعم طيب ماذا عن الاوضاع الميدانيه
الساعات الماضيه كانت تشهد ارتفاع في
وتيره المواجهات العسكريه ما بين الطرفين
كيف يبدو الحال الان
يعني الجيش الاوكراني بدا بزمام المبادره
داخل مدينه القوات الاوكرانيه تتقدم وبحسب
يعني وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه وبيان هيئه
الاركان العامه صباح هذا اليوم ان الجيش
الاوكراني بدا يستعيد بعض المراكز التي
تراجعت وانسحبت منها قوات داخل مدينه ضخمه
الجيش الاوكراني ايضا يعني عندها الساعه
الرابعه عصرا قصف مخزن كبير مخزن الاسلحه
كبير تابع للقوات الروسيه في مقاطعه
دونيست وحتى هذه اللحظه يعني لم تستطع فرق
الاسعاف والدفاع المدني في تلك المنطقه
اخماد الحريق ويعني الدخان الكثيف لا يزال
يغطي اجزاء شاسعه من مقاطعه بسبب استهداف
هذا يعني المخزن العسكري الكبير والذي كان
يضم منظومات صاروخيه او مخازن لصواريخ
كانت تطلق على الاراضي الاوكرانيه ايضا في
مقاطعه خرسون الجيش الروسي استهدف محطه
القطارات في مدينه حورسون وقد نجح حوالي
114 شخصا باعجوبه اثناء دخولهم الى القطار
سقط سقطت الصواريخ ويعني حتى هذه اللحظه
لم يسجل سقوط ضحايا ولم يسجل سقوط اصابات
في محطه اطارات مدينه قرصون ولكن مدينه
قرصون ايضا تعرضت للقسط مقاطعه ايضا تعرضت
لسقوط مصادر تشير عن سلطات الاوكرانيه بان
هناك جرحى نتيجه هذا القصف الروسي ربما
تجاوز عددهم الاربعين
هذا بالامس كان هناك قصف لمباني سكنيه في
مقاطعه ولكن يعني انا لم استطع بسبب كثافه
الاخبار اليوم استطيع يعني متابعه عدد
الجرحى والضحايا ولكن كان هناك اخبار
عاجله تقول باستهداف لمحطه القطارات داخل
مدينه
خرسون وكان هناك القصف المدفعي الشديد
والعنيف على مدينه خرسون تزامن هذا القصف
مع يعني اعلان وبس تسجيلات فيديو حول
استهداف الكرملين وربط بعض المحللين
الاوكرانيين ووسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه
انها قصف مدينه خرسانه ومحطه القطارات جاء
ربما ردا على ما حصل في موسكو نعم هل
نتوقع خلال الساعات القادمه انه ستكون
هناك معركه تشهد مواجهه محتدمه للغايه
خاصه مع ما يبدو من تصعيد من قبل روسيا في
تصريحاتها السياسيه انه سيكون هناك رد
قاسي وعنيف
يعني يترقب ان تكون هناك ضربات صاروخيه
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه وقد راينا وحتى
بعض ضيوفكم كانوا يتحدثون ان النواب في
البرلمان في الدومه الروسي وحتى وزراء
وسياسيين كانوا يطالبون باستهداف مقرات
حكوميه اوكرانيه وان يكون الرد الروسي
عنيف على ما حصل في الكريمل ولكن الان
الشارع الاوكراني في ترقب حول ما كيفيه
الرد الروسي وكما قلت يعني ذكرت في نشرات
سابقه ان هناك يعني
يتحدث عن سيناريوهين حول ما حصل في موسكو
السيناريو الاول يعني يعتبر ما حصل
بمسرحيه قامت بها الاستخبارات الروسيه
تمهيدا لعمل عدوان كبير قد يطال الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وكان الجانب الروسي يبحث عن
ذريعه لهذا العدوان والان تم خلق او تم
يعني انشاء هذه المسرحيه كذريعه لعمليه
كانت تعد لما سمي بهجوم الربيع
نعم الجانب الاوكراني ومنذ ثلاثه او اربعه
اشهر كان يقوم بتدريب قوات خاصه وحشد
عسكري كبير وتاخرت يعني الهجوم المضاد
الذي كان يتوقع ان يكون في شهر مارس او في
شهر ابريل تاخر بسبب تاخير الدول
الاوروبيه تسليم بعض الاسلحه لاوكرانيا
ولكن بحسب وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني
الذي قال قبل اسبوع او في نهايه اسبوع
الماضي ان القوات الاوكرانيه اصبحت تقريبا
في الخطوات الاخيره لجهوزيتها للبدء
بعمليه بالهجوم المضاد او بما يسمى
بالهجوم هجوم الربيع الذي تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه الوصول خلال هذا الهجوم الى
حدود العام 1991
طيب كانت هناك تقديرات مختلفه لما يمكن ان
يكون عليه شكل الهجوم الخاص باوكرانيا
والتي كانت تهدد دائما به بانهم هجوم
الربيع هل بالفعل وصلت تعزيزات عسكريه
قويه من الغرب لاوكرانيا هل يمكن ان نكون
شاهدنا على الارض ما يشير الى ذلك
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه الجيش الاوكراني يكون
بالاستعدادات الكامله هناك حشد عسكري كبير
في يعني في مناطق الشرق هناك يعني وصول
معدات عسكريه كبيره يعني شوهدت بعض
تسجيلات الفيديو نشرت عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي عن تدريبات كان يقوم بها الجنود
الاوكرانيون في مقاطعه في استعدادا للهجوم
المضاد نعم يعني في منطقه ضخمه هناك تحرك
جديد وكما قال يعني زعيم مجموعه ان يعني
انه يرى ان القوات الاوكرانيه قد بدات
بهجوم داخل مدينه وبدات تستعيد بعض
المواقع خاصه في ظل شح الذخيره والاسلحه
من جانب من الجانب الروسي وقد راينا عدد
كبير من التسجيلات الفيديو كانت يعني تبرز
ان هناك قوات روسيه او مقاتلون او جنود
دروس وجنون المقاتلون من مجموعه فاغني
يلقون السلاح بعد نفاذ ذخيرتهم داخل
النقاط خاصه في مدينه دفع القوات
الاوكرانيه للت والان هناك حاله ترقب كما
ذكرت في الشارع الاوكراني لما لكيفيه او
رؤيه ماذا تقوم به روسيا خلال الساعات
القليله بالتاكيد الملف يشهد اشتعالا
وتوترا كبيرا بعد الهجوم على الكرملين
مسيرتين اوكرانيا تقول ان لا علاقه لها
بالهجوم والكرملين يحمل روسي يحمل
اوكرانيا مسؤوليه هذا الهجوم وامريكا تقول
ان ليس لديها ادله للتاكد من صحه ما وصفته
بالادعاءات الروسيه اذا نحن امام مشهد
مشتعل تشتعل فيه الساحه الاوكرانيه
الروسيه هناك تهديدات من الكريم برد قاس
في الوقت
والموقع الذي تحدده الرئاسه الروسيه وفقا
لهذا التقدير العمليات على الارض وفقا
ايضا للزميل محمد البابا تشتعل وبشده في
عده مواقع
هناك تنبؤات ايضا
ردود فعل وسعه من قبل روسيا كيف استعدت
السلطات الاوكرانيه لما بدا من تهديد روسي
بالرد السريع
طيب قبل ان نتابع هذا الامر لنتحول الى
كلمه لرئيس المسكي حيث يقوم بزياره الى
فنلندا
نرغب بان تسدل هذه الحرب
وتضع اوزارها باسرع ما يمكن
والرساله الى روسيا هي رساله واضحه
هي عباره عن الوحده التي حققناها فيما
بيننا فاننا ندعم اوكرانيا
والمواطنين في اوكرانيا فلديهم الحق بان
يتمتعوا بحياه سلميه
فهم الذين
سعوا فقط الى بلوغ سلم عادل
هذا ما شددنا عليه في اجتماعنا اليوم وهذا
ما سوف نستمر في قوله
الى الشعب الاوكراني السؤال الاخر
اود ان اطرح هذا سؤال على الرئيس
زينينسكي وعلى رئيس وزراء الدنمارك هل
ناقشتم اي تفاصيل
ترتبط بالدعم المادي من قبل دول شمال
اوروبا
قبيله انعقاد قمه مجلس المجلس الاوروبي
الرئيسيه
الان
نعم لقد تحدثنا عن استمرار الدعم من قبل
كافه دول اوروبا الشماليه وليس فقط
الدعم الدفاعي بل دعم اقتصادي من اجل
اعاده البناء فاجزاء كبيره من هذه البلاد
فائزه
الان بزياده حجم دعمها الى اوكرانيا ولقد
تحدثنا كثيرا حول
القمه المقبله للمجلس الاوروبي لان
اوكرانيا سوف تكون هي محطه تركيز ليس فقط
حول المسائله بل ايضا حول كيفيه احلال
العدل هناك وسوف يستخدم جزءا من هذا
الشمال للتركيز على بعض القضايا المحدده
ولا سيما بالنسبه لمعادله السلام التي
قدمها
فضلا عن استثباب واحلام العدل
ومشكله المسائله وهناك ايضا واحده من
النقاط الاخرى ضمن النقاط العشر المتعلقه
بالنواحي الاقتصاديه
في ظل الدمار البيئي الكبير الذي تعرضت له
اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا
اود ان اخبر دول اوروبا الشماليه باننا
ممتنونا للغايه على دعمكم
السخي في ميدان المعركه وعلى ما تلقيناه
من شركائنا
وانني ممتن لكافه دول اوروبا الشماليه عن
تعبيرهم على الوحده والتضامن مع اوكرانيا
في بعض المسائل المحدده بعينها وليست فقط
في المجال العسكري واني اتطلع الى هذه
القمه المقبله
المجمع عقدها
وعلما بانني اتيت الى هنا لاعبر صراحه
باننا لابد لنا ان نعبر عن امتناننا
الكبير لدعمكم اللا محدود منذ اندلاعي
الحرب من يوم منذ يومها الاول واعود ان
اشكر القيادات الاوروبيه
على حجم الدعم الذي شهدناه منكم سواء في
ميدان المعركه او في التامين القوى
الدفاعيه المطلوبه وعليه اود ان اشكر كافه
الدول
والدول التي سوف تكون حاضره في القمه
المقبله شكرا لشركائنا
شكرا
السؤال الى انسقي والى
وزير الخارجيه الدنماركي
البعض يتساءل بانه لماذا يتوجب علينا ان
نثبت قدراتنا في ميدان المعركه قد
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا قبل حصولها على المعدات
العسكريه طبعا هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
الرئيس الاوكرانيه مع مجموعه من قاده
اوروبا في فنلندا يقول لا يهمنا كثيرا ما
يحدث في روسيا ولكن نحن مهتمون
باسترداد اراضينا وهذه رساله واضحه لروسيا
على حد تعبيره نعود مره اخرى لمتابعه
التطورات المتعلقه باستهداف الكريم
واتهام موسكو لكياب بتدبير هذا الهجوم
ينضم الينا مدير تحرير موقع اوكرانيا
اليوم محمد العروقي مرحبا بك سيد محمد كيف
يمكن قراءه هذا التطور هل نحن امام صفحه
جديده هي الاكثر
انفلاتا والاكثر تصعيدا في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه موسكو تتحدث عن استثناء رئيسها
تحياتي لكم وللساده المشاهدين يعني حقيقه
نحن امام موقفين موقف روسيا يتهم الجانب
الاوكراني بتنفيذ هذه العمليه وموقف
اوكرانيا في تماما ضلعوه بهذا الموضوع اذا
نحن بين المنطق وبين العاطفه يعني ده بين
المؤيد والمعارض قد يتهم اوكرانيا ولكن
بالمنطق ما مصلحه اوكرانيا من هذه العمليه
هل اوكرانيا اذا نفذت هذه العمليه واغت
السيد بوتين هل تتوقف الحرب اليوم تنسحب
روسيا الى حدود العام 91 على سبيل المثال
اوكرانيا تحضر وتعد ما هو اكبر من هذه
العمليه اوكرانيا تحضر وتعد لي تحرير
اراضيها في هجوم اوكرانيا مضاد فبالتالي
اعتقد ان يعني وجد النظر الاوكرانيه بان
هذه مسرحيه بها شيء من الواقع والتشكيك
والتشكيك الدولي ايضا
او تلجا موسكو في الوقت ذاته لمثل هذا
النوع من المسرحيات على حد هذا التعبير
ساحدثكم لماذا يعني الان اقرا على
التليجرام يعني قال ان هذه مجرد طائرات
كانت لتدريب يوم 9 يوم عيد النصر يعني
الان هناك تداخل في الانباء وسوف نعلم بعد
قليل الكثير ولكن لماذا تلجا
واضح الكريملين تحدث عنه استهداف له
بمصيرتين ونشر فيديوهات لهذا
نعم اشاهد الان على شاشتكم هذه الفيديوهات
ولكن كما قلت بعض المشاهدين على التليجرام
والنشطاء من موسكو يقولون ان هذه كانت
لتدريبات لحمايه الاجواء يوم التسعه مايو
انا لا اؤكد ولا انفي انا اقول على شبكات
التواصل ما يقال ولكن لماذا لجات لماذا
لجات روسيا الى تلك العمليه روسيا الان في
موقف الدفاع وليست
موقف الهجوم بالاراضي الاوكرانيه منذ
ثلاثه او اربع اشهر لم تحقق اي انجاز وعلى
سبيل المثال هي في محمود منذ اكثر من عشره
تستطيع الاستيلاء عليها الجيش الاوكرانيا
يتقدم عبر النهر شرقا في في
خطوته الابداد في منطقه
كما ذكرت الصواريخ الروسيه التي تقصد تقصف
تقصف اوكرانيا تسقط معظمها فوق السماء
الاوكرانيه فبالتالي روسيا الان اصبحت في
موقع الدفاع في جزيره القرم نشاهد اعمال
عسكريه واعمال حربيه قد تكون
في بدايه هذا الاتصال نحن امام روايتين لم
يثبت حتى اللحظه صحه الروايتين او اي
روايه فيهما ولكن السؤال الان بغض النظر
عن من فعل هذا الفعل ما هي التداعيات التي
يمكن ان تحدث نتيجه هذا الهجوم
يستطيعون الرد على ذلك نحن الذين نعيش في
اوكرانيا مجموعه صواريخ سوف تقسم بها
روسيا اوكرانيا قد تلجا الى اساليب جديده
غير قصف يعني غير القصف المعتاد على البنى
التحتيه للطاقه قد تلجا الى قصد يعني مقر
حكوميه سياديه ولكن اعتقد ان اوكرانيا
الان مؤهله لصد تلك الصواريخ نحن كنا
نشاهد في الماضي يقصف مئه صاروخ ويتم
اسقاط 80 الان يقصف في الاونه الاخيره في
خلال يومين الاخرين ما بين 23 و18 صاروخ
يتم اسقاطها معظمها جميعا لا ينفذ الا
صاروخ او صاروخين فبالتالي اعتقد ماذا
تستطيع روسيا اكثر من ذلك يعني قصف صاروخي
ولا يؤتي ثماره ولن يحقق نتائجه حتى في ظل
الشتاء الماضي عندما قال الجميع سوف تتجمد
اوكرانيا خرجت اوكرانيا من هذا الموضوع
ونجحت في حرب الطاقه بل صدرت الكهرباء
الشهر الماضي لكل من بولندا والسلوفاكيا
والمجر فبالتالي روسيا لا تستطيع فعل اكثر
مما فعله ودعونا لا نغلب العاطفه التي
نتحدث بها بالاحاديث الجانبيه بان روسيا
دوله عظمى وتستطيعها ولكن نحن نعيش على
هذه الارض اصبحنا نسمع في الاونه الاخيره
بان اسفل ما كان هنا وهناك دون ان نحس به
في الصباح فبالتالي اعتقد على روسيا
الانسحاب من الاراضي الاوكرانيه والتفاوض
يعني يكفي هذه العبديه مساله التفاوض ما
يحدث اليوم يشعر الكثيرين بان مساله
التفاوض او السلام باتت بعيده للغايه في
ظل هذه التطورات الدراماتيكيه هل يمكن
التصديق على هذه الرؤيه ام انه يمكن ان
تدفع التطورات بالعكس الى مساله التقارب
نعم نحن يعني اعتقد تماما اننا بعدون كل
البعد عن اي مفاوضات ولكن دائما دعونا ان
نقول ان قوه ان الدوله التي هي دوله
الاحتلال بيدها دائما الحلول بروسيا الحل
الاسفل يكمن بانسحابها من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وحينها يمكن التفاوض ودراسه
العسكريه لروسيا وهو ما لم تقبل به من
الناحيه النظريه
الحرب فوز وهزيمه الحرب فبالتالي يعني
اوكرانيا ايضا لن تقبل باحتلال روسيا
لاراضيها الغرب لن يقبل بفوز روسيا بهذه
الحرب ولن يقبل بهزيمه اوكرانيا والجميع
لا يريد روسيا يعني يعني ضعيفه مهزومه
الجميع يريد روسيا قويه مهزومه افضل من ان
تكون ضعيفه مهزومه لاخذ
هل نحن امام تحول استراتيجي فيما يتعلق
بوصول الهجمات الى قلب روسيا نتحدث عن
استهداف للكرم اذا ما صحت الروايه الروسيه
بغض النظر عما حدث هل هو من مؤامره من قبل
موسكو على كياب ام لا ولكن ان تصل هذه
الهجمات الى العمق الروسي الى الكرملين
الجميع الجميع يدركوا باحقيه هذه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وكل ما نطلبه من بوتين ان
يتخلى عنها وان يتركها لاصحابها
ومساله الخوض في هذه المعلومات المضلله هي
نوع من انواع التلاعب الروسي شكرا على
منحيا فرصه طرح هذا السؤال الموجه الى
الرئيس
صفقه الحبوب سوف
تنتهي في 18 من مايو هل هناك
اي نوايا او تخطيط من قبل موسكو لتجديدها
ولا سيما على خلفيه الهجوم الذي تعرض له
الكريم مما قد يحمل تداعيات سلبيه
انا لا ارى اي مصلحه لروسيا للاستمرار في
مبادره الحبوب وهذا ما قلناه في اكثر من
مناسبه
ونحن نرغب ان نرى تنفيذا لهذا الاتفاق من
قبل
شركائنا بصرف النظر عن تلك المبادره فنحن
لدينا اتفاقيه واضحه
التي كانت قد تمت برعايه الامين العام
الامم المتحده غوتيريش واردوغان الرئيس
التركي لدينا التزامات اتجاه بعضنا البعض
ويجب ان تستمر هذه الالتزامات فيما يخص
اتفاقيه الحبوب عليهم ان يتفاوضوا مع
الجانب الروسي
وتامين الممرات من قبل دول لايصال
كافه تلك الحبوب
وبهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه المؤتمر
الصحفي
شكرا شكرا جزيلا
اذا هذه تصريحات رئيس الاوكرانيه والتي
فيها قيام باي هجوم على الكرملين ويقول
نحن لا نستهدف روسيا ولكننا نحاول استرداد
اراضينا هذا اذا هو الرد الان منزلنسكي
على اتهامات الكريم لاوكرانيا بشن هجوم
بالطائرات المسيره على الكرملين هذا هو
التصريح الذي يدلي به الرئيس الاوكراني من
فنلندا حيث المؤتمر الذي جمعه برئيس
الفنلندي ومجموعه من القاده الاوروبيين
زينسكي ينفي تورط في الهجوم على الكرملين
نعود مره اخرى
لسيد محمد سيد محمد نحن امام اجابه قاطعه
الان ايضا منزلقي بانه لا مسؤوليه عن
استهداف الكرملين ويقول بشكل واضح لا
نستهدف بوتين الى اي مدى يمكن ان تؤدي هذه
التصريحات الى طمانه موسكو او ربما عدم
اشعال الم وقف اكثر من ذلك
يعني حقيقه كما ذكرت بدايه اللقاء
اوكرانيا غير معنيه نهائيا باغتيال الرئيس
الروسي بوتين اوكرانيا كما قلت معنيه
بهجوم مضاد لتحرير اراضيها فبالتالي ليس
من مصلحتها ان تقلب الموازين عليها
فبالتالي اعتقد لروسيا الان حريه يعني
تصديق او البحث عن الطرف الذي قام بهذه
العمليه ان كانت حدثت بالفعل يعني نحن نرى
على شاشات التلفاز انفجار بعد الطائرات
لكن اعتقد ان هذا مبرر روسي تريد ان تختلق
مبررا لقصف اشرس واعنف على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لافشال الهجوم الروسي
الاوكراني المضاد في القريب العاجل اعتقد
هذه من يفكر ايضا السيد محمد لماذا تلجا
موسكو لهذا السيناريو هي لا تحتاج الى
تبريرات هي تخوض هذه العمليات العسكريه
وهذه الحرب منذ فتره طويله ولا تقدم لاحد
اي مبررات
نعم هي لا تستطيع ان تقدم مبررات ولكن في
حدود في حدود يعني الخطوط الحمر يعني يعني
خطوط حمراء هناك رسماتها روسيا لنفسها في
هذه الحرب فهي لا تقصف مباني مدنيه بشكل
متعمد هي لا تقصف السكك الحديديه الى تقصد
بعضها الطرق والجسور قد تريد استخدامها
ذريعه لتوسيع الهجوم ابقى
معي في المستشاره سياسيه في مركز دراسات
الدوليه من موسكو سيده ايلينا ربما
استمعتي الى جزء من مقاله السيد محمد هو
يقول ان هذه الدعاءات كاذبه من موسكو
لمحاوله تبرير هجومها القادم على منشات
مدنيه كبيره في اوكرانيا ما هو ردك
مساء الخير نعم كنت استمع بدقه واستغرب
لانه من غير معقول على روسيا ان تقصف
نفسها باستخدام مصيره وهذا في قلب موسكو
في كريم لان هي هجوم من هذا النوع ممكن ان
يؤثر على سمعه القياده الروسيه ايضا امام
الجماهير امام مواطني روسيا
على كل ان هو الان روسيا ستستغل هذه الحجه
لتوجيه ضربات
موجعه على مواقع اوكرانيه هناك تصل
معلومات انه هناك حاله التاهب في قواعد
جويه روسيه في داخل روسيا مثل قاعده انجلس
وكانه الان يتم
او تحضير مقاتلات من طراز
طوق وهي ستقصف اكيد في الليل او في فجر
الغد المواقع الاوكرانيه مهمه وبراي هذا
القصف سيكون عنيف جدا طيب
يقول انه لسنا مسؤولين على هذا الهجوم
بالعكس ان بوتين يحاول من خلاله ان يحفز
شعبه لانه لم يحقق انتصارات عسكريه كبيره
حتى الان في اوكرانيا وبالتالي هي مجرد
دعايه وترويج لنظامه ولحربه على اوكرانيا
كيف يمكن الرد ايضا على هذا الامر
ايضا كلام مدهش جدا لانه
الان هناك انتقادات بسبب هذا الهجوم في
داخل روسيا الناس يقولون كيف القياده
الروسيه ام تسمح بذلك لماذا لا تنتقم وهذا
ليست اول مره هناك كانت اغتيالات بيد
متطرفين اوكرانيا في دواحم موسكو في مدينه
سانت بيتربوكا
للنشطاء روس يدعمون هذه العمليه العسكريه
فالناس يعتقدون حتى انه الرد الروسي على
محاوله تدمير جسر القرمه منذ سنين ايضا
الرد كان غير كافي بوجهه نظر الكثيرين
فالان هناك طلبات
بسار بالانتقام وانا انظر بكل الجديه لما
يقوله اعضاء البرلمان روسيا الان ورئيس
البرلمان سيد هم يقولون انه هذه المره
الضربات الروسيه لازما تكون مختلفه نوعيا
فنحن غدا لن نتكلم حتى حول طبيعه الهجوم
اليوم كيف صار وماذا وراءه لانه ستكون
هناك احداث مهمه
وسنركز عليها نعم ابقي معي سيده ايلينا
لاسمع الرد من السيد محمد سيد محمد السيده
الينا تقول بشكل واضح كيف لروسيا ان تعرض
سمعتها
لاهز شديده من هذا النوع تتعلق بسمعه
النظام وقوته في ان يتم استهداف الكريم
كيف يمكن تبرير ذلك
يعني هي بكل الاحوال هزه كبيره لكريملين
يعني الكريملين قبل ايام قال انه لديه
يعني مضادات وطائرات من الجيل الخامس
يمكنك التصدي لاي شيء ونجد مسيره تسقط
يعني في وسط
الكريب لان هذه هذه بحد ذاتها يعني يعني
انتكاسه لهذه الدوله العظمى لكن اذا كانت
اوكرانيا دعيني اقول ان الحرب ليست ملاكيه
الحرب شيطانيه وبها الجميع اسف على
التعبير جميع القدرات التي ممكن ان يفكر
بها الانسان ولا يفكر بها الانسان فلا
استبعد ان تكون جهه ما لا اريد ان اقول
روسيا ولا اوكرانيا دبرت هذا الامر يعني
لديها مصلحه اخرى فبالتالي لا هنا يعني
بالحرب انني سالطق سمعتي او سانظف سمعتي
المهم تحقيق النتيجه المراد من تم استهداف
خط النرد ستريم ووجهت لتهامات لروسيا ظهر
بطن وقال ان الرسل لا يمكن ان تقوم بهذا
الامر وبعد ذلك ثبت تورط اوكرانيا في هذا
الامر البعض ايضا لا يثق في الروايات
الاوكرانيه
نعم ما اقول لان في ذلك مع كل جهه حق في
التاييد او النفي ولكن لا توجد الان لا
يوجد تحقيق دوليه وجهه اصابع الاتهام في
نورس 2 مباشره الى اوكرانيا هذه الروايه
الروسيه تتحدث ذلك واوكرانيا ايضا تنفي
فلذلك نحن مع النفي حتى في جسر كيرش
اوكرانيا لم تؤكد عندما تم قصبه بالقرن في
اكتوبر الماضي اوكرانيا لم تؤكد ولم تنفي
ونحن نتوقع جميعا ان اوكرانيا من قام بذلك
ولكن في عمليه الكريملين اليوم اوكرانيا
بسرعه نفت هذا الموضوع الرئيس نفا والناطق
باسم مكتب الرئيس نفا فبالتالي هناك بعض
الامور التي نعلم ان اوكرانيا يعني مثلا
العمليات العسكريه المختلفه في شبه جزيره
القرم او في بعض المناطق العسكريه على
الحدود بين خارقه ودانيسك وروسيا نحن يعني
نعلم ان هذه اوكرانيا ولكن اوكرانيا حينها
تطور السيده ايلينا تقول انه
خراءات الاستراتيجيه المهمه الحيويه في
اوكرانيا واستخدام اسلحه متطوره وان هذا
ما يدور الان في البرلمان الروسي وهذه
ليست مجرد كلمات او تهديدات برد قاسي
ستكون هناك هجمات واسعه خلال الساعات
القادمه
يعني اعيش انا الحرب من يومها الاول وحتى
الان يعني الكل مطمئن وواثق بالدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه وبالجيش الاوكراني بصد
هذا الهجوم ونحن جميعا في اوكرانيا على
قناه لن تستطيع روسيا فعل اكثر مما فعل
مما فعله دعينا نتذكر ان شاء الله نعيش
حتى صباح الغد يعني اوكرانيا روسيا سوف
تقصد اربعين خمسين صاروخ سيتم اسقاط منها
35 او 45
في السماء لن يحدث اكثر من ذلك يعني اصبح
الشعب هنا على ثقه بذلك بسبب خبره الجيش
الاوكراني ووجود مضادات حديثه وموجود
محمد هو يقلل من فعاليه الضربات الروسيه
قبل ان تتم ويقول انها ستكون عباره عن
صاروخ هنا وهناك وانهم يستطيعون السيطره
على كل ذلك الامر وان الجيش الروسي لم
يحرز انتصارات كبيره والدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه تتصدى له دائما
لحتى الان لم تستخدم كل اسلحتها النوعيه
وبما فيها اسلحتها الحديثه وانا اقصد بعض
الصواريخ
وقنابل القنابل ايضا فراغيه
وصواريخ فوق صوتيا نعم تم استخدامها ولكن
ممكن ان تستخدم اكثر كمان كما لم توجه
روسيا ضرباتها على مراكز اتخاذ قرارات
عسكريه وسياسيه الان اعضاء البرلمان
الروسي يدعون لهذا الشيء واذا كان كنا
نسمع مثل هذه الدعوات من قبل بعض المؤيدين
للعمليه او بعض المحللين العسكريين
وما كنا ناخذها بكل الجديه الان انا اعتقد
حان الوقت لكي ننظر لهذا الشيء بكل جديه
لانه نحن ممكن
نكون امام مرحله جديده في هذه المواجهه
وانا براي روسيا كانت تحضر نفسها لهذا
الشيء لانه منظر الاشهر اوكرانيا يتكلمون
حول الهجوم المضاده واكيدا روسيا كانت
تحضر نفسها واكثر من مره القياده الروسيه
حتى كانت تسمع الانتقادات في داخل روسيا
انه لماذا القياده الروسيه لا ترد على
عمليات ارهابيه على اغتيالات وعلى
الهجومات باستخدام مسيرات
والى ضربات اوكرانيه في العمق الروسي اكثر
من مره قد حدث ذلك في الوقت الاخير فانا
متاكده انه قروشه كانت تصبر ولكنها كانت
تحضر نفسها للرد العنيف طيب سيده ايمينا
هناك تعزيزات بالاسلحه من قبل الغرب وهي
اسلحه متطوره تم ارسالها الى اوكرانيا على
مدى الفطره الماضيه والتقديره تشير ايضا
الى ان الجيش الروسي لم يستطع حتى اللحظه
احراز ما يمكن تسميته بانتصار عسكري ساحق
كيف يمكن قراءه هذا الامر ايضا
وعلى كل دول الغرباء هي وعدد كثيره ان
ولكن هي لم تنفذ كل هذه الوعود نعم صواريخ
حامله هي كانت مزعجه وما زالت بالنسبه
لروسيا ولكن هل هناك طائرات
مقاتلات نعم بعض المقاتلات من
من انتاج سفيتي قديم قد وصلت وبعدها لا
تستطيع التحليق حتى هو نحن كلنا نتابع كنا
ذلك فانا رايي انه دول الغربه هي هي ستكون
حذر جدا وهي لحتى الان ما قامت بتقديم
الدعم اللازم لاوكرانيا لانه اصلا
اهدافها هي غير كانت وما زالت وهو اضعافه
بكل الاساليب الممكنه ولكن ليس انتصار
اوكرانيا القياده الاوكرانيه لحتى الان لم
تفهم هذا الشيء وهذا غريب لانه ما نوعيه
الاسلحه الجديده التي يمكن ان تستخدمها
موسكو ويمكن ان تكون عوامل حسم اضافيه لها
في هذه المعركه ولم تستخدمها من قبل
مثلا في الايام الاخيره روسيا بدات تستخدم
دبابات حديثه من طرازه ارمادا روسيا ممكن
ان ايضا ان تقصف الان اوكرانيا باستخدام
قناه بالفراغيه هي تم استخدامها السابقا
ولكن ليس بكثافه
وبالاضافه لاستخدام مسيرات لانه هذا هو
نقطه ضعف لدى روسيا ولكن روسيا حاولت ان
تملا هذه الثغرات ايضا في ترسنتها
العسكريه هناك بصراحه وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
الان في روسيا بالتكهنات منها منها بعتقد
جنونيه لبعض بدا ان يشير الى امكانيه
استخدام اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه انا اتمنى ان
لا يحدث ذلك واعتقد انه هذا الشيء مبالغ
فيه كثيرا نعم ما هو ردك سيد محمد على هذه
التنبؤات وان كانت مستبعده ولكن الطرح
السلاح النووي مره اخرى في هذه المواجهه
هو مؤشر خطير للغايه
يعني نتفق مع ضيفتكم الكريمه من موسكو حول
موضوع يعني استخدام الاسلحه النوويه لا
اعتقد ان روسيا ستقدم على هذا لانها تعرف
الثواب والعقاب في هذا الموضوع هذا اولا
ثانيا انا اؤكد واكرر كلامي روسيا لن
تستطيع فعل اكثر مما فعلته منذ بدايه
الحرب روسيا استجده السلاح من الصين ومن
كوريا الشماليه ومن ايران ومن غيره روسيا
لديها نقص كامل كنا نشاهد في بدايه القصف
الواسع الروسي بمئه صاروخ الان بالكاد
يجمعون كل شهر او 40 يوم يعني 15 صاروخا
او 23 صاروخا روسيا لن تستطيع تحقيق اكثر
مما فعلته روسيا عليها التفاوض حتى لو
قصفت مقرات سياديه شو يعني قصد مقرات
صينيه اصبحت الان المقرات السياديه عباره
عن تطبيق في الموبايل يعني لن تهز الكيان
الاوكراني لن
تفرق القياده الاوكرانيه لن يعني تقطع
خطوط الاتصالات الان نحن في عصر
التكنولوجيا يمكن اداره الحكومه والدوله
كما ذكرت من خلال تطبيق في الموبايل
فبالتالي اعتقد ان على روسيا الاقتناع
بالتفاوض وهذا هو جدول الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد لاقناع روسيا اكثر بالتفاوض وان
نجحت اوكرانيا بتحقيق انتصارات هذا الهجوم
قد تقنع الغرب بمزيد من الدعم الاسلحه اذا
لم تريد روسيا
الينا ما يقول استاذ محمد مهم هل تقبل
روسيا بفتح مسار جاد للتفاوض بالفعل
ليس الان فقط بعد هذا التصعيد لانني لا
استبعد انه بالاضافه الى قصف شديد القوات
الروسيه ستحاول التقدم اكثر في مدينه
وايضا في يمكن في اتجاهات اخرى
نعم المفاوضات هتاتي ولكن بعد التصعيد
وبعد ما تظهر روسيا بانه نحن امام مشهد
تصاعدي بامتياز قادم خلال ساعات القادمه
وفقا لتحليلات المراقبين السيده ايلينا
سيبونينا المستشاره سياسيه في مركز
الدراسات الدوليه من موسكو تحياتي سيده
الينا وشكرا ايضا موصوله للسيد محمد
العروقي مدير تحرير موقع اوكرانيا اليوم
منك
[موسيقى]
ونذهب سريعا للمشهد الموتى وطور ايضا
اشتعالا في السودان حيث قال السفير دفع
الله الحاج علي مبعوث رئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان قال خلال
تواجده في القاهره ان الدعم السريع لم
يلتزم بالهدنه المعلنه ونكث بها وان الجيش
لن يلتقي بقيادات الدعم السريع وجها لوجه
بل عبر وسيط
نحن قبلنا
مبادره الهدنه السعوديه الامريكيه وليست
وساطه
لتحل النزاع حسب ما شرحت طرف الثاني الى
هذه
الى الان لم يوافق على هذه الهدنه او
النقص عن
افادته الاولى ورجع عنها حسب تصريحات
مسؤوليه اليوم
اذا استمرت هذه الهدنه الانسانيه التي
شرحت الدوافع التي جعلت من فخامه الرئيس
ان يقبلها
وفدنا لن يلتقي
بمن سيرسل من حركه التمرد
[تصفيق]
وجها لوجه ولن يقابله وذلك قناعه بعدم
اعترافنا وتصنيفنا لهم بانهم حركه متمرده
انما سيكون هنالك تواصل عبر الميسرين
اصحاب المبادره
هذه الاشاره تشير الى جده المدينه سعوديه
التي ربما تستضيف هذا اللقاء غير المباشر
وهو لقاء تكون مصادر صحفيه انه سيركز على
ترتيبات وقف اطلاق النار وليس التفاوض
السياسي السفير دفع الله الحج قال ايضا ان
على الجيش السوداني ان يوافق على اليه
خارجيه لمراقبه الهدنه وفق شروطه
لا قبول ولا موافقه لاي اليه دوليه
وللتدخل في السودان في هذه المرحله ان كان
ثم الدواعي لاي اليه
تسهل مراقبه الهدنه نحن اولا اقول يجب ان
تتم بالتشاور معنا
والوقوف على تفاصيلها
وموافقتنا ورؤيتنا ان تتم عبر دوائر
انتماءنا السياسي والتي تمثلها الجامعه
العربيه والاتفاق الاتحاد الافريقي بعد
التشاور معا
الله
اكبر
الامين العام للامم المتحده لشؤون
الانسانيه مارتن جريفيث قال ان المنظمات
الانسانيه في السودان تعمل بظروف صعبه
للغايه مشيرا الى ان هناك مشاعن للحصول
على التزام كل الاطراف لحمايه المساعدات
الانسانيه
مستلزمات الطبيه تنخفضت في دارفور بشكل
كبير كما هو الحال في انحاء البلاد وكما
تعلمون بان انخفاض المساعده الانسانيه في
السودان امر محزن في الاسابيع الاخيره نحن
نقوم بتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه حتى بدون
اطلاق النار في المناطق التي تحتاج
مساعدات في السودان
[موسيقى]
والعربيه مستمره مع حضراتكم في مواكبه
ومتابعه كل التطورات والاحداث في كتاب
والصراع مع موسكو وايضا في السودان سنلاحق
التطورات الساعه القادمه مع زميله ميسون
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات